Hello!
and clear!
Hoi!
Snake!
Wrong game!
Oh, I just realized I forgot to let me pop out my OBS.
Yes.
Moe moe!
Nice.
Moving my stuff around.
Oh, I will fix chat.
Welcome back to Apex.
Peace combat!
Yahoo!
How you doing, Minky?
I'm pretty good!
I, today, went and I got stuff for tomorrow's stream, which
is a hand cam.
I am making hand puppets.
I was like, what kind of puppets am I making?
Hand puppets.
So I went out and did that.
and a brand that I really like.
Gelato Piquet is, I saw it having a sale right now.
And I did some shopping.
So I bought some clothes and accessories.
Riden and Rose Hand Puppets.
Maybe one day.
I don't want to make a Rose Hand Puppet.
That was a very Beast Wars Megatron yes, yes.
No.
I feel like Beast Wars Megatron has changed my brain
chemistry of how I say yes, you know what I mean?
Mobius Mito Engage!
Today is my birthday, a victory would be nice.
Oh gosh, we're up against some tough missions today, huh, I
think, maybe.
No, tomorrow's hand cam, the puppets will be Densets.
So it'll be Vicky, Phoebe and me, which I have not, I was
supposed to make my own puppet last time I made puppets.
And I did not!
So yeah.
Dents.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And the actually, well I'll just mention it now.
if you're going to Faname I will be a guest at Faname but
also I was asked if I wanted to participate in a charity
auction and I said yes and they were like what would you
like to auction and I said well I can make puppets so the
puppets I make tomorrow will be auctionable you will be able
to you could get them for yourself and the money goes to
charity so I'll mention that again tomorrow too but yeah
yeah yeah you could have your very own den sets too I don't
know if they'll I imagine they'll probably do it as a set so
I would like to start making more puppets in the future as
well for future for those things so it won't be your only
chance but it might be a rare it will be a rare chance
so but yeah we stopped we did what six missions yes not
yesterday last yesterday yesterday stream yesterday year so
do you still have the Nimi puppet.
I gave the Nimi puppet to Nimi actually.
So Nimi has her Nimi puppet, but I do still have the Doki
puppet.
Whenever I say Doki again, I will I will give Doki her
Left off after Invincible Fleet.
I'm scared though.
No.
We can handle them maybe.
Maybe.
Ugh.
I don't think I've ever paid $50,000 for hand puppets, but
for charity.
I mean, it does go to a good cause.
It does go to a good cause.
What's the cause?
Actually, that's a great question.
They just asked me if I wanted to participate in a charity
auction.
do what apparently Fandom 8 does it every year.
Can you say the cause?
Steiner, what is the cause?
Eh, Steiner.
What's the charity?
Cause?
I hear charity and I'm like, yeah!
What's the charity cause?
What's the, what's the, he said, uh, what?
What?
Oh my god!
Hold on, I'm asking him if I could share what he just said.
Is this a scam?
Steiner, please respond.
I was like, can I share this with chat?
And he said, if you must.
This is what I just said.
So sometimes with Steiner...
Sometimes when he, like, has to check something, he just
says, sec.
And, like, you know, like, one second.
And this is what he sent to me.
Oh, my God.
That might be the worst ever.
Wait, I don't want to...
That's not a good cause.
I think he's busy.
Yeah, I think he's busy.
I cannot say anything because I do not...
check my text before i send them or things like that i just
type and then i said i knew that steiner was looking out for
us this is a great cause charity sick no
that's a great cause no
well i have to send the laughing emo there we go sent I sent
I sent that the wait what is it called on YouTube wispy
laugh I sent that amen that's a pretty good cause I don't
know if you should donate the puppets for that happy
anniversary to the big show incident whoo which also happens
to follow my birthday hoping you have a good mgs today nam
nai happy birthday
uh steiner said make a wish greater bay area that is the
charity congrats on the group cover oh thank you yes um we
were we were um we were asked if we would want to do a cover
of the opening song for, uh, oh gosh, okay, Neverness to
Everness.
New game!
And so, on the Den Zetsu channel, if you would like to
listen about that, I mean, listen to that, you can!
It's such a cute song!
It's a very cute song.
I know!
And the main character's name is Mint!
What the heck?
That's crazy.
Now there's like multiple mints in gotcha games.
I believe there's a mint in Miki as well.
But me, I am the original.
Actually, not really.
Galaxy Angel also has a mint.
There was a mint in Galaxy Angel.
Me, I am the second.
Oh, Arcanize 2?
What the heck?
I don't know about Arknights too.
Mint is such a popular name.
Mint Gongaga.
Miki Mint's not playable though.
She's like an idol, no?
After the VTuber Wars, all main characters will be named
Mint.
And I will rule them all.
Not sure if intentional, but it switches to Mint when you
hijack cars.
Neverness to Everness?
It might be.
Or you mean real life.
There is a mint in Nike.
Doki got confused when she saw your name in the concert and
thought you were in it.
I believe that event I was actually asked about, but I was
too busy to participate, unfortunately.
But now I'm like, if I ever get to do a Nike thing, it would
be fun if I could dress up as mint.
It's confused about the Stonehenge part during your last Ace
Combat stream.
I'm missing something.
I just don't get it.
What part?
Change your legal name to Minky.
You can just call me Minto if it's too confusing.
You can dress up as yourself anytime you want.
Stop!
know why hearing that was hilarious when I heard Stonehenge
before it was because in Ace Combat 7 I remember really
struggling on that mission I kind of had PTSD from it
you are in for some fun
after Zanzibar I was taken from the battlefield Neither
truly alive, nor truly dead.
Stonehenge is a tough mission in four.
I will do my best.
But, for now, I'm assuming it's not the next mission,
because that would be really scary.
Wait.
I think these are both the same.
Yeah, they seem the same.
Probably the same.
Probably fine.
Just gotta aim good.
Okay.
I can try.
Let's, uh, continue from the previous, wait, continue.
Deep strike.
Mission seven, yes.
We'll do the briefing again and everything.
Your next mission is to attack the soil power generator
plants in the Faith Park region.
These generators equal nuclear ones in Halfway.
Let me know how the audio is in real.
About 60% of the energy for the illusion's military
industrial complexes.
Since they do not require oil or uranium, supplies, we
cannot stop power production by interrupting their supply
lines.
This deep strike mission will not only cripple the arena,
but also divert the aspect ratio.
It was like a little messed up last time.
You gonna make it, Minto?
Believe in yourself?
You have the capacity and talent to be a pilot?
Trust me!
Thank you!
Oh gosh, I have to remember the controls.
Okay.
Let's see.
Why is my tummy hurting?
Um, no, A-Ted!
I think I remember people saying this one would be good for
this.
This mission.
Am I crazy?
Hmm.
Try it.
The Mirage.
Oh, this one's new.
What does a TND sound for?
Multi-role fighter that features both air-to-air and
air-to-ground capability.
Tornado!
Mirage, my beloved.
I'll try it.
I'll try.
I can afford it.
Is this one also new?
Oh, it is.
Yeah.
Multi-role carrier-based fighter.
Okay.
Holy...
I wonder, this one seems a little more...
able to carry virtually every weapon ever made!
This one seems like it might be more well-rounded than the
Mirage.
Am I crazy?
Well, if I could see.
If I could see anything.
I guess the Mirage is faster.
Tom Cruise plane is F-14 and Super Hornet.
Hornet.
This is legacy Hornet.
Hornet is a workhorse for sure.
I wonder if we...
What did I...
What do I have right now?
I could sell it.
And we could try the F-18.
Multiple roles.
Plain useful for both ground and air.
Yeah, that's how I feel.
Okay, let's...
Let's sell whatever...
What do I have?
What am I using?
Oh, my F-16!
Alright.
Goodbye for now.
We might bring you back.
Oh, that might... Is that enough money?
It was pretty expensive.
Hope there's no ocean facility missions.
Might get shot down by a man who doesn't even know what's in
Halo 30 in this.
Oh, I can!
Yippee!
sell the f4 it does not let you it even says you cannot sell
the default plane it gets mad at you otherwise i'll show
i'll prove it to you i'll prove it to you default aircraft
cannot be sold
you look like an f-18 kind of gal what does that mean do we
have any new weapons
Wait, oh, for my F-18.
You.
Yes.
Multi-target.
Four targets at once.
This one can only air to surface.
We're blowing up
the solar generator, right?
Our stuff.
Actually, I remember what they said how many targets they
said solar panels yeah good
range and accuracy
it's a ground mission yeah so maybe
this one yeah i can't afford both dang it that's okay all
right Let's go.
Oh, okay, hold on.
I'm looking at my controller real quick.
I'm gonna need a second.
I'm gonna take a second once we start the mission to
remember how to...
How to yawn, how to everything.
How to ye, how to yawn, how to...
Missile gun.
This has changed... Triangles changed target.
Oh wait!
I can just do this!
Oh my gosh, why does my tummy hurt?
What the heck?
Stummy hurts so much all of a sudden.
Oh, the square's the map.
Okay, okay.
How to ye, how to yaw.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Level the aircraft.
Oh, change the...
Okay, yeah, yeah, that's important.
Awesome.
Okay.
Hey!
Eikimasu!
Pre-flight tummy butterfly?
It must be.
Deep strike.
Mission 7, let's go!
My dad is an engineer that worked on the F-22.
And I think I got this own when I said that my favorite
fighter jet was the MiG-19.
I just think it looks cool.
You're dead.
I can imagine like a...
His eye twitching.
You have to be from the Middle Ages to ye.
Hear ye?
Hear ye.
What?
Don't lose sight of my wing.
Who's my wingman?
Keep your guard up.
I'm going at a...
Oh my gosh, sorry.
I ain't going home in a body bag.
I'm hanging out with my friends.
Actually, they're like really way ahead of me.
Engage already?
Oh, I see one.
Uh...
There we go.
Okay.
Omega 11 Engage.
Mobius 1.
Engage.
Alright, I'm getting back into it, you guys.
Here they come.
I don't know if that will hit, but...
Hit!
Miss.
I am.
What do you mean I'm in too deep?
Talk to me?
There he is.
Got plenty of ammo.
Locked on.
Smoke in the air?
Oh, yeah baby!
We'll get rid of these guys real quick.
You're welcome.
You're welcome, my friends.
Okay.
Nice, nice.
Yeah.
Uh.
I don't know if this will hit.
Probably not.
Oh, I felt like it was close.
again
no you're not I'm on your tail
that'll get him yeah baby my barrel rolls I'm so sorry where
am I going uh wait um what is north wait
wait just kidding it's so much easier to see where i'm going
this this way you know why why i don't have a okay here we
go why i don't have a thing on here here we go she improved
so much from last stream i didn't have time to practice so
i'm kind of nervous about it to be honest
what is north what's a north what are you doing out here
What are you doing over here, friend?
Oh, alright.
He's on my tail.
I'm in a breakthrough.
I'm gonna get his butt.
I'm gonna get his booty.
Watch this.
Leave them to me.
BOW!
Beautiful.
Clean.
And easy.
One...
Oh!
I got one hit at least.
Where'd he go?
It's below me.
I'm like so high in the air.
Oh, no, not now.
Why'd you say that?
You jinxed me?
Yeah, baby.
I'm gonna lose all my... Oh, never mind.
I have like a lot of missiles.
Okay.
Let's go this.
It's this way, right?
Don't let the enemy spook you.
Don't let them spook you.
I'll spook them back.
The game is one guy in her.
I can't believe he said now!
Why would he say that?
I have to be a little careful, though.
I'm afraid of crashing when I'm so low, you know?
Because the way I, like, flip around and zip, zip, zip, zip,
zip, zip, zip.
And then I don't know which way is up and which way is down.
We'll get here.
Oh!
Oopsie!
Uh.
That's awkward.
Oh, should I start destroying these or?
Uh.
Oh.
Oops, I didn't mean to send two.
Dang it.
Warning!
Uh oh.
Shoot.
Hard right!
I'm yawing!
I'm heeing!
Let's get these guys out of the air.
first what is all this what is all this anyway no i'm never
sloppy i could never be let's get this guy uh shoot we're
going where do you go he's behind me
there he is come on What do you mean?
Why?
Oh, I thought.
My bad.
Oh, there's so many.
Oh, they're like, oh, these are all little explosions.
What are all these for?
Ouch!
Oh, maybe we can get...
Oh, where'd that guy go?
You.
Maybe?
Damn.
Missed.
It's okay.
We can get him now.
Yee-hoo!
That's right, baby!
Oh, I hit.
I hit.
Still a hit.
I'm just totally ignoring the cannons that are like...
What?
That are like exploding around.
Destroyed, baby.
Ouch!
Oh, gosh, I'm at 40%.
Uh-oh.
Uh-oh, go, go, go, go, go, go, get out of here, get out of
here, get out of here, get out of here, okay.
Maybe I shouldn't ignore them.
Okay, so is it now time to start?
Maybe I head back.
You think I have time?
Fly low to avoid the booms.
Is that how it is?
Actually, where's my targets anyway?
Where are my targets?
Or is it just a...
Actually, I can't tell at all.
Ah!
Could have to learn how to fly low?
Okay.
Triangle time.
It doesn't impress in it, but...
Oh, I see!
I see them, I see some.
Wait, some that are actual targets.
No like.
You.
No good.
It's a miss.
And you.
No you over there.
No you.
The other you.
Yeah, you, you.
My target is neutralized.
Attention all aircraft.
Incoming from Stonehenge confirmed on radar.
Wait what?
Drop
below.
Red toward the ravine and terrain mask.
Here's the premises.
Get low and stay low.
What are you talking about?
It's suicide to fly into that ravine.
Are you kidding me?
AHHHHH!
Descend to lower altitude.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Five, four, three, two, one.
Impact.
Oh my god.
like going so slow right now I'm like going so slow he's
like right on my ass oh my god oh my god oh my god I'm gonna
crash I'm gonna crash I'm
going so slow though he's on my boy
oh my god oh my god oh my god i'm holy cow oh my god oh my
god i'm holy cow
i felt like i felt like i was going at a literal snail's
pace i'm like
If only you guys could see how much my hands are...
They'd be shaking.
The mission succeeded, but the combat losses due to
Stonehenge were not expected.
Holy cow!
Unless it is eliminated...
Stonehenge!
Cabal, cabalow, cabalam!
Rest in peace my wingman!
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, I wonder what happened to what...
I think my wingman died.
Maybe.
Okay.
Yippee!
okay that was crazy first try at some point I realized my
uncle my would-be guardian had vanished oh where'd that guy
go maybe the secret police dragged him off for some drunken
comment he made maybe he chose to disappear his car I didn't
have anyone to take over my kiddies so I found myself living
as if I remember the yellow squadron first try and you
nailed it thank you Bob I was...
I was inching along, but we made it.
He joined the very squad he wanted to defeat.
Everybody in town scorned the barkeep for doing business
with the enemy.
In reality, he and his family were members of the
Resistance.
Whoa.
Gathering up intelligence information from enemy customers.
From Attack on Titan.
His daughter protected me.
get milk beer and never came back yeah but that was only
because of my tender age
the barkeep and his family were the real heroes while i on
the other hand found a haven among the enemy oh no
is this gonna be so sad at the end
No spoilers, of course.
Oh, shattered skies!
The name drop!
Name drop of the game.
A recon satellite will be launched from the Komona Islands
rocket base to support our mainland operations.
Oh.
The eruptions responded by deploying a large number of their
airspace.
superiority fighters to prevent the launch.
A large scale pair battle is expected.
We must win this battle to maintain our air superiority.
Yeah, air superiority.
We've only got one window of opportunity for this launch.
Shoot down as many fighters as possible to preserve top
cover over the rocket base.
Peak mission incoming!
Oh, 27 in the air!
Holy cow!
gosh okay wait actually I also I just realized I'm really
glad that I used that what was it was it the F-A-T because
it wasn't so fast that I didn't feel like I was gonna die in
the in the in the in the canyon that's the part the
protagonist says like it or not I am the ace combat oh four
Here's the dogfight mission you wanted me to!
Yeah!
Let's see.
Tornado.
Okay.
No new, no new plane.
I think it's time for the F-14.
Because I mean air, we need all air to air.
We don't need no ground, nothing, nothing.
We need...
Oh my gosh!
Wait!
It's time!
Wee!
Yeah!
Okay, okay.
Wait, let me sell.
Let me sell.
Let me sell you.
Goodbye.
We need money, money, money.
Boy, boy, boy, boy, boy.
Money, money, money.
I can't read.
Okay.
It was too bright.
Purchase.
Ah yeah!
Highway to the danger town.
Nothing.
Wait.
What do I have for my weapon here, homer?
Whoa!
Okay, cool.
We already got it.
Nice.
Okay, let's save.
I can't believe I won.
I did that last mission first try.
I feel like I was so...
I felt like I was...
There were so many close corners.
And I can't believe I did it.
Yay!
Yippee, yippee, yippee.
Oh, so happy.
You felt the tension.
I did!
Oh, goodness gracious.
Okay.
Ikimasu!
F-14!
Peak OST?
Okay, I'm gonna turn it up a little.
Score at least 800 points within the time limit and continue
to destroy enemy forces.
Are you gonna play zero?
Uh, yeah.
I will play zero.
What was it?
Four, five, zero, six, and then the next one.
And then eight.
Whenever that comes out.
Let's go!
Oh wow, they're already right here!
This is Komuna Base.
I
don't know if that was good.
I think it was a miss too.
It's alright, that's alright.
Let's meet at home if we make it home alive!
We will!
Please, please.
Miss!
Oh my gosh.
Oh damn it, that was a bad one too.
Okay, it's all right.
It's all right.
It's all right Come on, come on Yes All right, we got one I
got six minutes
Oops, I think I shot too early.
Yeah Missed Where'd he go there he is
Maybe...
Oh, whoops.
Maybe for this I want to be.
Oh shoot, he was so much closer.
Where is everybody?
It's just me and this guy.
I think I got him?
Yay!
Dirty, darting, darting.
Splash, baby!
Oh, everybody's all...
Hi, I'm on my way!
Don't lose...
Who's my wingman, anyway?
Oh, okay, I'm targeting on somebody who is...
Where the hell are they?
Oh my god, there's so many.
Wait, oh, there they are.
Okay.
Yeah!
Where is he?
Uh...
Oh my gosh.
Let me try a different guy.
Everybody's going crazy man.
This is crazy.
Oh.
Oh, someone got me?
Fox 2!
Ow!
Missile alert!
Who's shooting?
How many did the yellows get?
Hard enemy radar fight.
Locked on!
Shoot!
I don't think I got him either.
Oh my god, there's so much happening.
This might take me a couple tries.
That's okay though.
Where is he?
Where'd he go?
Oh!
The yellows are very good at dodging.
Yeah, I can tell!
I'm trying!
Uh, maybe try.
Are they all above me?
I'm just gonna try and go for anybody, but I can, you know?
I lost them.
Who's on me?
Oh, there you go.
Oh my god, they're so freaking fast.
We're like, okay, time to get good at the game.
I want to get...
Is everybody above me?
Am I too low altitude?
It seems like it.
Everyone's so high up.
I need to turn the music down just a tiny bit.
Okay, there we go.
Where do they go?
Focus on yellow planes, but like aren't the orange ones like
the better...
Yeah!
Baby!
Aren't orange ones the better points?
Orange are more points.
I don't know if that'll hit it.
I knew it.
I'm starting to get that issue where the sky blends into the
ocean.
Come on, come on.
Come on.
Oh, shoot.
I think I just lost.
Maybe, maybe, maybe.
Yeah!
Splash one, splash one, splash one.
Holy cow.
This guy's like right on me.
yes that was that was really lucky actually that was so
lucky how many points am I supposed to get like a hundred
hundred fifty or something oh shit I only have a minute left
there's no way
800 wait oh I'm at 400 yeah there's no I saw 60 and thought
that's how much I was at but oh there's no way yeah I got to
be faster holy cow the Sun is in my
eyes holy cow it's just like six minutes to launch no
there's no way wait why don't I have six more minutes then
huh give me six more minutes oh hey
I got over halfway.
All right.
That's okay.
Sad music.
That's all right.
Ikeimasu.
Attention all aircraft.
This is Komona Base.
Come on, Abyss!
I think I can get them.
Wait.
Yeah, baby!
I'm gonna head in.
You can dodge and me too!
Change your special weapon!
Oh my gosh!
Thank you guys!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, let me try it for, let me try it on
a, oh, holy cow, let's not crash.
Unless, that'd be so exciting.
Why won't it launch?
Wait, oh, they, it did, they're just kidding.
Holy!
Whoa!
Dang it.
That was a total miss.
That's okay.
We can do it here.
Like that.
I think.
Nice.
I think I don't know how to use it correctly.
Or rather, I don't want to, like, you know, waste it so
much.
Let's go back.
Where are you?
Where's my guy?
I just need to take out some guys.
You.
Where?
Where is everybody?
Am I crazy?
Where is everyone?
Oh, hello.
I'm not spooked at all.
I'm just lost.
I'm not spooked.
I see only friends on the map!
Oh, uh...
Missed.
I can't.
I'm sorry.
I'm like struggling to read the map so much.
It's north.
West.
Right.
It's north.
Oh, ish.
Well, maybe.
Oh.
That ish.
That.
Okay.
Wait.
Ah.
Oh, they're so fast.
Holy cow.
Let's meet again.
We'll meet again.
Ah!
Destroyed!
Yay!
I took the shot.
Yes.
We're close.
Oh.
Oh, dang.
Okay.
Hit.
Dang it.
Didn't go on.
I didn't get him on.
Ah, shoot.
Oh, wait.
No!
You took on my kill!
I think...
Dang
it.
It's really just like find anybody.
That's in... No!
Why can't I get some of the points then if I did some of the
damage, huh?
Oh, dang it, that was not good.
Break, break, break!
Oh, shoot.
I broke, I broke, frog.
Oh, there we go.
Okay, we're fine.
We're not fine.
Yee-yee-yee-yee-yee-yee-yee-yee-yee-yee, all right, where is
somebody?
I mean, a little tiny ant.
Maybe?
Oh, you.
No!
I pressed it!
Please!
Yes!
Oh, just a minute!
I need to get, what, two more?
I think.
Please, please!
Lurse!
Yeah!
Okay, okay.
One more!
Break, missile!
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, okay.
Uh, just one more.
Just one more.
I don't think it'll... Actually, am I?
Am I hit?
Yeah!
Oh!
Don't I want to try anymore?
Box 2!
Oh.
That's alright.
Rack up the points!
Yep, I'm gonna do that.
I'm gonna do that.
I'm gonna get this guy.
No, I'm not.
I'm not gonna get that guy.
Oh, get that guy.
Never mind.
Bonus points!
That guy, that guy right there.
Okay.
Do you want me to go?
Except them before they reach the launch site.
The west.
Negative contact, nothing on my radar.
Look harder.
The B-2s are difficult to detect on radar.
There's stealth.
The west?
This way?
We're all going this way?
There's stealth?
What's going on?
What?
Just concentrate on your duties.
Five minutes to launch.
Oh.
Is it this guy?
Are these... No, these are not our targets.
No?
Right into it?
Okay, no.
But I'm still going to...
Oh, I see them, right?
Targets are red.
Yeah, I thought so.
Am I the only one that's...
Going?
My friends are ignoring it?
Or something?
Oh, targets.
Come on, come on.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, that was really unfortunate.
Come on.
Oh, wait, I could get this guy, baby.
Oh, come on.
This is bad.
Friends?
Where are my friends?
I think from behind is, like, easier to know.
Oh, please.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm just mowing them down.
Mowing them down.
Come on.
Okay.
They didn't even try to fight.
Uh, by me single-handedly, I might actually be the ace.
wait why was it so easy though um team are we okay
yeah they're bombers but like they didn't try to swerve or
anything stealth bombers are very slow oh i see
you got to them quickly so you had a lot of time oh awesome
we're so good at this guys Let's go us!
Let's go team!
Team, are we okay?
I'll help out.
Oh,
that was close.
I think I should go back, honestly.
Uh...
Two minutes to launch.
Damn.
Uh, hold on.
I think I need to actually, like, go back there.
there's gonna be more.
I don't know if there will be, so I'm just gonna go back.
The raw missile.
I know I pressed it on accident.
You didn't see that.
Don't point it out.
These are specials?
I'm out of them.
Yeah.
Let's not crash.
I guess.
I mean, why not?
Yeah.
Oh.
I've never done this before.
If I crash, do I...
Mobius 1.
Take off immediately.
Okay, we're fine.
.
Wow!
The rush!
Final launch checks complete, launch in 60 seconds.
We're gonna get this guy.
Trust.
This guy, they're gonna get him.
We're gonna get him.
We're not gonna get him.
We're not gonna get him?
We might get him.
Oh, we got him!
Oh, indeed!
Where'd all my friends go?
Okay.
Most confident pilot.
Thank you, not so Deadpool.
Welcome back.
Thank you so much for two years.
That'll cry, boys.
Woo-wee.
I think they've...
I think they're running out of, like, motivation.
They're very sad.
They're sad, sad.
They're really sad, actually.
Wait, what's happening?
Where are we going?
Ignition.
Oh, our satellite!
We're launching the satellite, right?
I've just been focused on this one guy.
Oh, so close.
I wonder.
Yeah, baby!
Oh, that was close.
Yay!
I got a couple extra kills in even!
40,000 feet.
It is now immune to enemy enemies.
YAHOO!
Thanks to you, the launch was a success.
Yay!
More than double extra kills?
The rocket launch proceeded smoothly, and all systems are
gone.
Preparations for providing our troops with vital tactical
data is now complete.
Nice.
pilot stover yeah everything's fine everything is good now
look I even got a rank buddy everything nothing could go
wrong don't clip that it won't be long now and then put it
it won't be long till it begins the bar keeps daughter
confided to me as a member of the resistance she eagerly
waited the ally counter-attack on the mainland what will
happen to these people when the allies come.
I asked, to which she frowned.
We'll run them out.
This is our town.
But I knew she didn't mean that from the bottom of her
heart.
Thumbnail.
Thirteen had captured her heart.
I knew this from the way she shot jealous glances at his
wingmen.
As other pilots rotated out of Yellow Squadron, Yellow 4,
13's wingman, always stuck by his side, even on land.
I mean, I feel like that's how wingmen are, though.
The only female pilot in the squadron, she had Yellow 13's
absolute trust as his wingman.
Yellow 13 seemed oblivious to all this, and instead reviewed
the promising enemy pilot's performance from yesterday's
skirmish.
Says plane.
He's so close.
If he manages to stay alive for just a while longer, that
pilot could be your...
worthy opponent that pilot such enemies to look forward to
13's eyes were sad
that pilot huh
silence woman i only care about worthy opponents yeah that's
how it feels like operation bunker shot we're into january
now Chat frozen, thank you.
The troops are regrouped and ready to reclaim lost territory
from the erosions in the amphibious Operation Bunker Shot.
The plan requires our forces to follow an extremely narrow
and vulnerable path from the landing site to the inland
objective.
This path allows the enemy to concentrate their fire and
provides them with a distinct advantage.
However, this route lies out of Stonehenge's effective
range.
reduced to casualties at the beach landing sites.
Oh, the beach!
Eighty-three on the ground!
13 in the hour.
Wait, so what is...
I'm just...
Oh, is this another points mission?
I was in the mood for a horror monster manga and was
recommended Monster Musume.
I found it in a bookstore sealed in Plowsick.
Must be really gory!
unfortunately so that's okay that's okay I
think we have a new one wait is this one new actually I
can't tell
air to ground and air to arrows how it's fast but its
stability is not so great His plane is his wife.
You need to understand he just wants to fly his metal bird.
No need women.
No women allowed.
Well, they're allowed.
But not in his heart.
Allowed in the team.
Allowed in the squadron.
But not in the heart.
Yeah, the mix seems really fast.
I wonder maybe...
Dare I say, too fast for this mission.
I wonder if we should...
But then at the same time, if I want to take out some guys
in the sky, if they're being a pain, you know what I mean?
There's only a couple of them.
Or tornado.
This one might be better.
F-18 is well balanced.
That is true.
Honestly?
That is very true.
Because definitely we want to switch.
planes for this in general.
I think I can just buy it.
I can just buy the F-18 without having to sell.
But Minto can't aim with gun.
Hey!
I shot some things with the gun last time.
I tried.
And it worked.
Okay, we'll try the tornado I'll listen to you guys we
actually I might need to sell to buy to afford oh no we're
fine layer to ground spread boom looking
at how many this one has 12 guided free fall bomb precision
attacks on surface targets with the lock on this one has
eight Long range, long range.
Might be better for me.
Fire and forget weapon capability of attacking surface
targets.
We'll try this one.
Has lock on and AoE.
ATMs are the fastest.
Okay.
Good, but most ground targets aren't worth a lot.
Ah, that's fair.
What better?
It got...
Anti-ground bomb.
Almost looked like...
Oh my god!
Like a nuke!
That's crazy.
Use my stock.
PG, please.
Just use what I have then?
Okay.
I'll try it.
If we don't like it, we just, uh, we come back.
We can always do a different loadout.
It's no biggie.
Hello?
Oh.
I always press triangle because triangle is to go back, but
you have to press X.
Okay, let's go!
F-A-A-B.
Okay, new plan.
Air to ground.
Bomblet dispenser.
Potent anti-surface weapon, which uses multiple bomblets for
a large coverage area.
That sounds probably what we would want, right?
reference to the manga red prowling devil in which the
protagonist flies the same plane oh the big 29 whoa really
that's cool score at least 2 200 points within the time
limit and continue to destroy enemy forces hawk i like how
they tell you to continue to destroy this is lieutenant
bales commander of unit bf around beach we do not have air
support this is uh hq friendly they're like Keep taking out
the enemy.
Move over.
Yeah, it's really icky out, huh?
Watch me earn my ace wings today!
Can we get this guy?
I'm engaged, baby.
I'm engaged.
That's what you just said, man.
You just said that.
He's worth 64.
Oh, whoops, that's not what I meant to do.
Maybe over this way is better.
Ground Beach.
Infector 3.5-0.
On the nose.
Oh, why am I upside down?
We're on the beach.
Check behind you.
What's behind me?
Let's see my guns.
To my left and to my right.
These bad boys pack a punch.
Can I get it?
I'll run the beach.
I keep hearing we're on the beach.
We're on the beach.
Wait, okay, I'm gonna go out a little bit.
And then we're gonna...
Because it's an orange.
I'd like to get it.
But why isn't it locking on is my question You know, I'm
like my altitude my altitude is crazy.
Oh, it's not a lock
When do I well when do I it does it does it go?
Does it Does it Is it Or is it...
You know what I mean?
Oh, I think I just launched all the way over there.
Wait, was that me?
Wait, am I doing anything?
What?
Wait, I'm actually...
Wait.
Why isn't nothing shooting?
Wait, where is it shooting to?
Um...
It bombs between...
Hold on, sorry, I'm just trying to look.
I don't see what you're talking about.
It's shooting below.
Is it?
I don't see at all, though.
Wait, I'm just gonna shoot.
The one's down there?
What?
The whole thing is going out!
Look third person.
Scoot, squeot, squeot, squeot, squeot, squeot, squeot.
I can't say I can't tell it at all I think I need to switch
weapons I think this one I'm not compatible with I hope you
guys don't mind if I I think I I think I don't understand it
that's okay though
Yeah, I think I got confused because I expected my brain
felt like I got this and then I okay.
That's why I was very confused.
That's okay.
Sorry, my bad.
I don't even know what was going on.
I'm eating either.
Okay, let's try that again.
Let's try that again now.
All right.
No.
You.
I was so confused.
The weapon didn't like your vibes.
Happened to the best of us.
That's okay.
That's why you're allowed to...
That's why you're given multiple weapons to...
To buy, you know?
You don't have to stick with the ones that you don't
understand.
No, I'm doing my own thing.
So, I also, I do want to see how this one works, too.
Omega 11th engage.
Nice.
Enemy facility destroyed.
Yay, baby.
Be calm and give it your best shot when the enemy arrives.
Thank you so much for the proof!
I got the thank you!
This one's kind of funny, okay.
This one like looks so funny.
Okay, so it's supposed to be like a, it spreads out, no?
Let's see.
Destroyed?
uh i'm gonna go for the tank let's go for the tank
we're on the beach nice oh shoot
who is shooting at me oh wait is this guy this guy is uh oh
Still have...
Steveen, then.
Surface target destroyed.
Now let's go into the little...
Hello, you in the air.
Did you come to hang out with me?
Are you here to hang out with me?
Oh my god, the villain...
Sorry, I keep turning side.
I'm like, I look like a puppy.
Being like, oh, oh.
I landed you.
My acceleration is like crazy nothing.
I'm just ju- I'm cruising.
I probably shouldn't be.
Oh, this is a timed mission.
I forget.
Locked on.
Mobius 1, box 2.
We're gonna fall!
So this should like explode a bunch of them, right?
Or something?
Enemy facility destroyed.
Going down, swinging.
Number one with the bully.
Something, something complex, cock it and pull it.
If they're close.
So they do have to be close.
Maybe the other ones, the Sammies would have been better
then.
Since I'm kind of...
What?
That's fine, maybe.
Where are you?
You.
The radar.
Beep.
I'm out of those so maybe actually I should probably go home
and then restock I'm kind of far why are there so many
allies at the border down there why are they all down there
we could really use some help why are you guys all the way
over there
missiles are good too I don't trust myself it's fine we got
time Actually, I don't have that much time.
That's okay though.
Alright.
They don't move?
Well, I move.
That's the issue.
We'll try over here.
Friend?
Friend, are you okay?
You need help?
You need help with this guy?
Is this guy bothering you?
Oops.
I missed.
Friend, I got you.
Is
this guy bothering you?
Hostiles confirmed.
Mobius 1, Fox 2.
No!
Please!
Yeah!
Fox 2!
I'm
back.
Cool moves, thank you very much.
If I can, like, get them fast, you know, it's, like, not bad
to...
But I don't want to, like, you know, you don't want to focus
on one guy.
You know what I mean?
So it's, like, tough.
If you're, like, boom, like that, then it's easy to just...
Oh.
To just take care of it.
Let's get the one in the middle?
in the middle?
One in the middle?
Get the one in the middle!
Fine.
Uh,
okay.
Oh, wait.
There's more down here.
I was trying to switch targets.
I was pressing triangle.
It wasn't doing it.
I swear to you.
For some reason it was not registering or it just didn't
want to switch targets.
That's okay.
Oh see now it does.
There is a orange target over here that I would like to...
That will get you the battery.
Shoot!
Go?
Did my thing launch?
Oh, it did.
Okay, good.
Halfway there, but I only have a minute left.
It ain't looking so good.
Wait.
Ooh.
Woo!
Oh,
it's only hit.
Do I need to do two?
For these?
I feel...
I'm not quite sure.
They're strong.
I have one left.
Where, um...
Destroyed?
I don't know what is targeting me.
I feel...
I know I'm being...
I know I'm kind of slow, but at the same time, I'm like...
What can I do to get more points?
Hmm...
Like what would be best to...
You know?
Hmm...
Hmm.
Just gotta use my regular missiles too.
These time missions need a run or two to learn targets and
loadouts.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm trying to decide if I want to change...
That's why unguided bombs is better because they get better
radius to deal with multiple...
Yeah, but I couldn't figure out how they were firing at all.
I don't think that's useful if I can't figure it out.
Like, if I can't use it properly, then I think it's not
worth it.
A10 rip and tear.
These missions are just so boring.
And I feel no motivation.
F-16 with multiple targeting again.
I think that honestly might be my best bet.
If you hold down the fire button, the camera will follow the
fired weapon.
Good way to see how it travels.
Oh, really?
Okay.
K-10 has quad air-to-ground missiles.
It does.
Do
you guys think I was low enough?
Because people say, like, fly low.
I feel like I was pretty low.
But...
Where are you?
I'll
tell you.
altitude was okay.
Just hard to see the bomb hood.
Yeah!
Oh.
Okay.
Let's get this.
Let's try it again.
I would do the A10, but it's just so slow for how I play.
Multi-target air to ground.
Okay, let's try that again.
We keep trying.
I think the right has like the best gun.
Maybe.
We could go from the right to the middle, maybe.
Or something?
I don't know.
They put you so far out that I'm like, okay, it takes like a
second to get there, Anna.
Ended confirmed Invictor 340.
Invictor 040, 8 miles.
Let's get these orange babies.
Yeah.
Love the orange guy.
I am!
You see, I'm doing my job.
I'm doing my job.
How low can you go?
All the way to the floor?
Can you bring it up top?
They can have it never stopped?
Alright.
Enemy facility destroyed.
Oh, oops.
We're destroying something.
But will it destroy the pillbox?
Engage.
Enemy facility destroyed.
I don't think it did, did it?
Where's the other orange?
Hold on.
I'm trying to find the orange.
Is it you?
Oh, okay.
Now I'm locked on it.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Give me a second.
What's here?
What do you mean by here?
All right, all right, let's get this tank.
Oh, it didn't oh it hit it didn't destroy though
Oh, okay, we'll take this guy real quick
Nice Alright.
Where is it?
Hold on, I gotta turn around.
Installing.
Maybe now it'll destroy?
Destroy?
Okay.
Alright.
You there first.
You little tank.
You second tank.
Oh, okay.
You!
And you third tank.
Is that towards me?
Another battery?
Hopefully.
Destroyed.
All right.
Just a visual flare.
Anything else?
Anything else over here?
Not enough, probably.
Maybe.
Oh.
I'm going the exact opposite way of where I need to go.
I can't see the HUD with the subtitles in the way.
Thank you.
All right, there we go.
Mostly a clean beach.
Dang.
Calling her a clean beach?
What soap does she use?
It's kind of nuts the difference a right plane can...
I know, right?
Like, it does, honestly, like, make a crazy...
difference for me at least you know maybe not other people
but when I'm like you know when I'm able to when I'm able to
like you know properly know what I'm doing I feel so much
better oops that's not what I meant to lock on that's okay
though we want we want that guy
I want that orange.
Yeah.
I don't know if I sent the second one.
The Bunkas.
Oh, why did I do that?
I thought I was locked on.
I'm such an idiot.
Where is that guy?
I can
get this battery real quick.
Oh, it's not an orange battery.
Where'd the plane go?
That bunk, guys.
Did I get
him?
Oh.
I heard it.
I don't think I did.
I don't think I got him.
Oh, maybe I did.
Just kidding.
No, it's just a hit.
Whoa.
I'm almost out.
I think I accidentally sent more than one, but that's okay.
I can't tell how many of these guys take.
One.
This'll hit.
Is it you?
Who's the one shooting at me?
We're right next to each other.
Oh, shh.
Don't.
No!
This is your B.
We're pinned down behind the helicopters.
There is this guy.
Oh, there he is.
Oh, he's so low.
Oh, I might be able to get him.
I might be able to get him.
Yes.
Okay.
Oh, please.
Leave me alone.
I just need a couple more points.
Okay, hold on.
I need to go around and turn around.
I'm struggling a little.
If I make this one, I will not be stuck.
Yay!
We did her!
Yahoo!
Alright.
Oh, I'm almost out of missiles.
I probably shouldn't engage with this guy.
I'm gonna go back home in the 30 seconds that I have.
Yeah, I get back to the line.
that's what i'm doing that was pretty close though in terms
of how many missiles i
how many missiles i had left holy cow i would have had to
switch to actually using my gun might have been bad news
bears caution oh doesn't return to base
yes i hope you were able to try the bomb someday maybe i
mean i don't think that you You have to learn how to use
every weapon.
That's my philosophy.
Mobius 1.
You are cleared for...
I mean, I think it's, you know, if I can be...
If you can be really good at 1 or a couple, you know, then
that's...
I think it's okay.
Uh, where are they coming from?
Okay.
Me don't...
On the way.
8-10s, you say.
Imagine if we were also fellow A-10.
Where are these guys?
Oh, there they are.
Missile!
Thank you!
Ah, shoot.
Missed!
Let's go for another guy.
It's like no one to take the shot, so, you know.
It's important.
No, no one how your missile...
Oh, shoot, I missed, I missed, but...
Where'd he go, actually?
There he is.
Locked on.
Box two.
I think I got him.
You missed.
I know how to shoot.
I know I even said to know how to shoot when to shoot and I
missed.
How could I?
Maybe.
Radar lock.
Missed.
Oh.
Oh, that would have been perfect.
You weren't talking to me, were you?
Fox 2, Fox 2.
Ah!
Trashed.
Oh, there's bandits now.
Where'd they come from?
Oh my gosh.
A 10
shot down by me, baby!
Missed!
They're not supposed to be called missiles because you
always miss!
Thank you.
Now what?
Oh, there's one last guy.
I think this is the last one, no?
Maybe?
Yes?
No!
Missed?
Missed.
Ah, shoot you, Charity.
Ah, so close.
Don't call it trash.
Don't call me trash.
You, you're annoying me.
Wait, uh oh.
Ah!
Where?
I lost him.
I lost the target.
Because... No, please.
Me neither.
Okay, we got him back again.
Oh, shoot.
Please don't hit me.
I know.
I'm trying to get him.
Ah!
Missed.
Check six.
Where is he?
Oh, come on.
That shouldn't have missed.
I'm trying.
My target!
Yes, thank you.
Can I at least get a guy?
They're so annoying.
They're camping him.
Where is my team?
All I have to, all I keep doing is going left, right, left,
right.
Oh my god, I'm not gonna beat this because I can't stinking
get this guy.
one guy.
He's one guy!
Please.
Hit.
Ah!
Please!
I'm getting one guy for real.
Can you guys take care of the other people?
Oh!
Hard enemy radar spike.
Check six.
Missed.
Oh!
What are my friends doing they're absolutely useless to me?
Did I get them oh my oh my how do I get my god?
Sorry,
oh my god.
Oh my it's an a-10.
It's an a-10
Fox 2 Fox 2 hard enemy radar.
My god I got a target
30 seconds.
I had 30.
I had 30 seconds.
Unit B appears to have secured Crown Beach.
10-4, good job.
The mission is a success.
Unit B, Commander, didn't you have some message for the
pilots?
That guy was...
This is Sergeant Collins.
I've taken over command of Unit B.
Tell them thanks for the supporting fire.
Where?
Where were you guys?
Where were you?
Everybody here!
Rip bales.
F-16 really is the Minto fighter jet.
Small, snappy, reliable, and has a great smile.
Look at me go!
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Your back must be sore from carrying your team.
A feature was established through fierce fighting at each of
the landing sites.
8.5 for Minto go.
I don't know why it couldn't get him though it was all part
of the I did it because it would be so easy if I got him too
quickly duh Mobius don't Mobius 1 don't need no help you're
right yeah it was for the content we're tangling wow yeah We
made it through, though.
We made it through.
That was the world's best A-10 pilot.
How was he so zippy?
It wasn't an A-10.
They just said it was.
Vistas Fortress is a strategic foothold on that line.
It utilizes unique terrain features that make it virtually
impregnable.
Support our troops by attacking and neutralizing the combat
power of Vistas Fortress.
Before more, there are no ghost planes or haunted planes.
I'm not afraid of heights.
I wonder if your skills should prove to be more than a match
for it.
Wait, sorry.
I need to listen to that one more time.
Again!
You're in range of Stonehenge again.
Oh no.
Wait, let me watch, sorry.
Let me watch the briefing one more time.
The Tango Line is a vital line of defense for the Erosion
forces on the eastern mainland.
ISTA's Fortress is a strategic foothold on the island.
line it utilizes unique terrain features that make it
virtually impregnable support our troops by attacking and
neutralizing the combat power of Vistas fortress oh wow this
will put you within range of Stonehenge scary however your
skills should prove to be more than a match for it oh oh no
oh wait wait wait wait that sounds really scary it is a
ground mission again this game is loves ground missions.
One second, I'm gonna get a cough and drop.
I was fine.
My throat has been like, it's okay.
Now it's not okay.
It's okay.
Today it was not okay.
That's okay, though.
Cough drop, okay.
No, don't at me.
The screaming earlier might not have helped.
Maybe.
It's so Yeah, my throat's been sore the past, like, week.
I don't know.
I think I'm going for the F-18 again.
Or maybe that...
I think the F-18 would be better.
I love the selection menu.
It's like, me too!
Speed is pretty useful here.
Well, then maybe...
This guy.
Fast Plains help you get far, and this map is very big.
But maybe the MiG-29.
Hope your era has been better to me, though.
It has, thank you.
I think the MiG-29 is a bit better at air-to-ground than the
FF10.
Can't wait to see you listening to the select menu.
After Mission 12?
Oh, I have to listen to it next stream then.
since I was going to do 12 to 18.
Yeah, I'm using both earphones.
It's not perfect.
Like, my hearing or my ear is not perfect.
If anyone's curious, my ear has been a little icky these
past couple of days.
But...
Oh, whoops.
I didn't mean to do that.
I'm going to sell the 16.
There's...
snake voice coming in what does that mean you'll be
streaming for an oil rick suit uh i asked if you won that
midnight doctor gotcha i didn't but it's my fault i forgot i
should have set an alarm for it and i didn't i
think we'll go did i try the mc29 earlier i feel like we
need something more well-rounded for this maybe i didn't
maybe it was the f-18 that I did more stability is always
nice too oh the 29 is new oh okay mmm
let's try the f-18 oh whoops there's
obviously more ground targets than there our air targets but
the lasso the lasso the
boom and boo you mean the boo and boob
lasso up all right probably would be better yeah
um wait so do i have to be like really low to the ground
because of oh gosh
Don't have to be...
Squirtly's 3,000 points!
Avoid Stonehenge's tech!
Sky Eye here.
We're inside Stonehenge's engagement zone.
Be careful.
They may shoot.
First played Ace Combat 4 when I was about 6!
I've been obsessed with planes ever since.
That's so awesome!
Wait, what's Sky Eye over there?
Check your planes.
You see that island of orange?
I'm going that way.
Don't be predictable in heading around the tube when they
close in.
My least favorite mission?
Well, we just got to get through it then.
How often do they...
Does it shoot?
How did they build a base here?
Oh, it's so foggy.
Resupply base in vector 340.
More mines.
Maintain a high rate of fire.
AA guns destroyed.
Dang, I'm already at 20%.
Okay, hold on.
Where'd all the orange go?
Oh, it's down in here.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my
god.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
I'm just shooting.
Oh my god.
Holy cow.
I'm getting out of here.
This was a trap.
That was terrifying.
I'll just stay low, just in case.
Came from afar.
I was getting shot at in every single possible way.
Oh, God.
Needed a bit more altitude.
No kidding.
No, you're not.
Check behind you.
There.
The.
The cough.
The cough
drop I used was so strong and it like got it stuck in my the
the not the cough drop itself but the taste of it got
stuck in my throat
holy cow all right i wish the tall base the vector 070 8
miles i feel like things the the what's it called should
scale the points don't scale you know what I mean be tall
base at vector 0 5 0 actually can I go I can't go I just ran
into it
you get some in the water is there some in the water I'm
just getting watch towers at this point facility destroyed
how did I miss
Where is water?
I've been on land this whole time.
It's okay.
I'll probably... I know I will have to do this mission
again.
3,000 points is kind of... Oh, my bad.
It's kind of painful.
Hello?
Can I... Target this guy?
Can I target this one right here?
The one in front of me?
The guy in front of me!
Oh, that's my friend.
I can't even read.
That's a guy.
That's not my friend.
All aircraft descend below 2,000 feet to terrain mask.
Oh, Stonehenge is coming?
Here they come!
Dive for the deck!
You're toast!
I'm on the wrong!
What do they expect us to do?
Fly through the mountains?
My bad.
That's why.
I was on the wrong missile type.
That, uh...
Ten seconds to impact.
Eight, seven, six, Five.
Old aircraft hit the deck and prepare for impact.
Holy cow.
Is it done?
Where's the water?
Some people said get the ships.
Oh, whoops.
I don't even see any water.
All I see is land.
Land and land and land.
I'm at work.
Maxie, good luck with work!
I'm so, I'm lost.
This map is humongous.
Oh, they give you a lot of time, though.
They mean the river.
Oh, that.
There can be guys in there.
It's so small, though.
Are there any guys in the river?
Down, down, down by the river.
Wait, there's something over here.
Maybe.
My.
We'll pass it.
Don't even.
Are we serious right now?
Is it a ship that's attacking me?
Maybe if I...
Okay.
It's a Sam!
It's a dang Sam!
Okay.
Honestly...
I'm gonna go where all my friends are at.
I'm ignoring every single one of you and I'm heading this
way.
This is a tough mission.
Confusing for me.
Submarine dock at vector 360 Forman.
Submarine?
Hit the dock from the front to get a missile in.
In the front.
That's a gunboat?
Did I...
Oh, I destroyed him though.
Oh, damn.
120 points.
That's like major.
Use the deck to shelter the warships.
What?
No, the dang mountain.
Oh, no, come on.
No, come on.
Nice.
Oh, I'm out.
Shoot.
I'm out.
Okay, what if I go really high in the air?
Then I point down.
Where?
Actually, good plan.
Actually, there we go.
Sub-base.
But they said I could only get it from the front, no?
Or something?
Wait.
Miss!
Uh...
How miss?
The front...
What's the front?
Their 45 facilities are located in and around...
Oh, that's just a watchteller.
Ouch.
It's okay.
I'm trying to just get a feel for things right now.
You have to fly low and shoot through the front doors.
Knock knock.
Wait, where am I anyway?
Actually, I'm lost.
I'm in the trees.
Where am I?
I missed the entrance.
Just like Top Gun, too.
Yeah, for real.
Not a Top Gun.
Hard enemy radar spike.
Here we go.
Sorry.
I know I'm really doing poorly on this one.
I'm not quite...
I'm like attempting, but also not really.
You know what I mean?
I'm trying to find a way in here.
Backstreet, backstreet.
what the wait i thought i was inside i'm like so off where
am i i can't read this map at all practice makes perfect
exactly we're just we're just trying to get a feel for
everything right now uh what i'm going the i think i'm in
the wrong mountains
Warning, incoming from Stonehenge.
Of course there is.
Miss, miss, miss, miss.
Miss, miss, miss.
All right, here we are.
I'm inside.
Oh, shoot.
They're right in front of me.
Two seconds to impact.
Eight, seven, six, five, four.
Wait, I'm okay.
Yeah, my altitude is below.
What happens if you are above 2000?
Alright, here we go.
Which is the front door?
I am trying to...
Okay, sub-base?
Is that it?
Wait, which one is that targeting?
It's right there.
Oh!
Is this also a sub-base?
That's a sub-base.
How did I miss?
Oh, is it because it's inside the base?
It'll kill you in one shot.
That's crazy.
Oh, I think I'm going to crash here.
Oh, I didn't.
I'm a genius.
Oh, dang, I got it.
Oh, I'm fine.
It's like so much work, though.
I mean, I guess you have to for this kind of thing.
Right?
But then how do I get...
Enemy vessel sunk.
Obvious one, Fox two.
I'm just taking them out one by one.
Enemy facility destroyed.
Hmm.
Nice run.
I wouldn't say that.
Yes.
Oh my gosh.
Destroy it.
Obvious one, Fox two.
Is that everything in here?
No, there was that sub.
Huh?
Oh shoot.
I like how I keep getting targeted and then they keep
hitting the walls.
You know who hasn't hit the walls?
Me.
Stupid.
Wait, which is the one that's...
Oh, wait, now it's actually gonna...
Sam destroyed.
Enemy facility destroyed.
Time right there!
Oh, that's... Oh shoot, wait.
Oh, oh, oh!
I'm an ace!
Like how I'm literally going the slowest pace ever.
That was close.
Wait, let's go around.
And then I can probably get inside.
So ridiculous.
Like, maybe through here.
I don't know what the front door is.
That's just the issue.
You know?
Is that it right there?
Oh, yeah, baby!
Oh,
what sucks is I still don't think...
Wait, do you guys think I can actually win?
I don't know if I can...
I have four and a half minutes, and I'm only a little over
halfway.
it is.
Maybe if you hustle, I was like, I was just dicking around
for so long that I feel like, now I'm like, wait a second.
I don't think I can hurry and do it, though.
Hmm.
I'll keep trying.
I'm also at 73% damage.
I'll keep trying, but if it don't happen, it don't happen.
Alright.
Here we go.
Uh, where's the next...
Okay, that one area that I tried to before, that I was like,
what the hell is this?
Wait, actually, where is that?
Down here?
Yes?
Yes, I think.
Something I can.
Gotta go fast.
I might... I am literally...
I'm squeezing R1.
Oh, wrong, wrong direction.
Let's get rid of these sands, because they're so annoying.
Fox 2, Fox 2.
Sam destroyed.
Yeah, that's what I thought.
Uh, actually, I don't even know where the other one is.
Wait, am I inside?
No, I'm so far away.
Good, he helped me get back to...
on track?
What am I targeting?
Or what am I locked on?
Ew.
What is exploding in the air?
Poor Sam.
What about poor Minto, huh?
Sam destroyed.
Sorry if your name is Sam.
Enemy vessel sunk.
Flak.
Flak being fired from below.
It's so hard because I can't tell, like, the terrain if I'm,
like...
Properly.
All right, let's get in here.
There's some containers.
Shoot.
Oh, there's a flak gun.
I got it.
Oh, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
Oh, shoot.
Mobius 1, box 2.
Enemy facility destroyed.
I have two minutes.
Okay.
I can definitely feel like I can do it next time.
I just really...
I now know I understand better, I think.
Okay.
warning incoming from Stonehenge okay actually that works
out for me oh gosh sorry
you're annoying let me take you out you're annoying take you
out containers take you out ten seconds to impact eight
seven six five four impact
mission fail we'll get up next time I'm almost tempted I'm
to not even continue, but I'm just gonna practice and not
hit the walls like that.
Dang.
How am I so good?
Oh, I missed.
What's worth a lot here?
What are you worth?
Oh, you're worth 100 points.
My altitude is insane at the moment.
Let's get that bad boy.
No!
I won't let you!
I think I just hit the wall.
Oh, no.
I got him.
Dang, we actually got pretty close, all things considered.
Dang, that's just...
Wait, what is the orange in here, though?
What am I missing?
Wait, no, I didn't get to see...
What was it?
Only about 500 points...
For how much I was just like, I don't know what I'm doing
for so long.
I feel I feel pretty confident I feel like maybe other
people took out planes and that's what made it easier in the
second half Oh container ship Is it that guy right there?
One second though I'm gonna go to the little ghosties room
Give me one second Let's go to the ghosties room I'll be
right back
Oh cute Okay
All right guys Let's do it.
Thank you, thank you.
Welcome back.
Thank you, all right.
Oh, I thought the music would keep going.
Sorry guys.
Let's go!
Wait.
Am I going toíamos?
Wait, am I going the right way?
Little more over.
Little more over, little more over.
Not turning my head.
A little more, less over, a little less over?
Keep your guard up!
Resupply base, dead vector 340, 8 miles.
Alright.
Can I, I can't, there's the entrance.
Resupply base, dead vector 340, 4 miles.
Their watchtower, they'll never know what's coming!
Uh...
Fox 2, Fox 2.
Fox 2, baby.
It's me.
It's me!
Oh, oh, come on, come on, come on.
Oh, it's the wrong way.
I went the wrong way.
It's a me.
Wait, did I go the wrong way?
Oh, somehow I did.
Wait, I went inside the entrance, no?
Didn't I go inside?
Sam.
Oh, no.
Okay, good.
Oh, there it is, there it is.
Oh my gosh, sorry, guys.
Sorry for all the flipping around.
So sorry, so sorry.
Oh,
God.
Enemy facility destroyed.
So annoying.
Fox 2, Fox 2.
Enemy facility destroyed.
Okay.
Return.
You've been hit by a missile.
What happened to you?
All right, let's see if we can get these Sam's because
they're kind of a...
Wait, can I get the ship?
Didn't I get the ship?
Oh, shoot.
It's okay.
All right.
Flat gun.
Black gun.
Antenna.
A artillery destroyed.
All right.
Where's it coming from?
Oh, I see him.
Let's get this guy.
Oh, I ended up shooting out, too, on accident.
I don't know what those are.
I'm just trying to hit anything that...
I'm trying to clear anything that I can in here, basically.
Okay.
AA artillery destroyed, enemy facility destroyed, enemy
vessel sunk.
Oh, I'm still gone fishing!
Oh, one second.
My bad.
Thank you.
Good fishing.
All right, uh, give me, uh, out of here for a second.
Fox 2, Fox 2.
Sam destroyed.
Sam.
Destroy...
Can I...
I think the fuel tanks were...
Pretty important.
We're already almost to...
Attention, all aircraft.
Ah!
No, already?
30 seconds to estimated impact.
All aircraft descend below 2,000 feet to terrain mask.
Which I kind of have been already, but it's a little...
Okay.
Dive for the deck!
A direct hit from one of those and you're toast!
I can't get inside!
No!
GAMBARING!
GAMBARDAY!
Thank you!
GAMBARIMBAS!
GAMBARIMAS!
Okay, we'll just cruise for now.
We'll cruise until it's over and then we'll do a big
turnaround.
A couple of you?
How?
You just go below 2,000!
All right.
We'll just keep focusing on this little area while we can,
you know?
And then...
Oh my gosh.
Wait, that's not a...
Holy cow.
I thought that was a turn.
I'm...
Oh, I don't remember how to get inside.
There it is.
Shit.
Yeah.
I was saying what?
What was I saying?
Tournament!
All right.
Change places.
Okay.
Alright, alright, alright.
Alright, alright.
Wait, is...
Did this thing miss?
Enemy facility destroyed.
AE artillery destroyed.
How did it miss?
There's still the orange.
Oh, I hit the roof.
Wait, is it another one of those like...
I gotta get it in the door?
Oh gosh, oh my gosh, wait, I think I'm gonna...
I think I'm gonna crash.
Where's the door?
Where's the front door?
I can get the fuel tank at least.
And that guy over there.
Boat container.
Enemy facility destroyed.
Nice.
Crazy.
Ah!
It's like half covered.
Wait, how do I get uncovered?
Oh,
we got one!
We got one!
Eww!
Get me out of here.
Oh, wait.
Woohoo!
Okay, now we gotta go do the things with the battleships
inside the doors and that good stuff and everything there
instead.
At least I have some friends over here.
Submarine dock at vector 020, 8 miles.
Landing confirmed at vector 100.
Go do the thing.
I will.
Nice and easy.
I don't know.
I don't remember how to get in yet.
Okay, I'm about to pass it.
Or something.
Here they come.
What's in here?
Yes.
Oh, shoot.
Ah, I got all.
I got all.
Crazy.
I got all... One more time.
One more time.
Oh!
Ouch.
Ouch!
I also still have these bad boys.
I just remembered.
I have my specials.
Guess who's too high.
Guess who's figuring it out, huh?
Guess who's...
Guess who's figuring it out!
Okay!
Wait.
Oh, I went the wrong way that's all right though dang that
has like such a long range okay um oh i'm like completely
turned around all right is sam figuring it out sam is never
coming back you'll never see sam again missile missile
you're talking to me vended confirmed at vector two
Alright, it's uh...
Uh...
Enemy facility destroyed.
Get in there now.
Help!
Oh, it's just a watchtower.
Ouch.
No.
Warning.
Incoming from Stonehenge.
No, I don't wanna...
That guy.
There we go.
No, the other one, the other one, the other one, the other
one!
Nice.
10 seconds to impact.
8, 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, and impact.
Oh my god, wait, how do I lower my altitude?
It's climbing!
Oh, wait!
Okay, we're fine.
That was so scary.
I was like trying.
I was like, oh my gosh, I think I'm going to go above 2000.
That was so scary.
Okay.
Wait, where am I going again?
This way.
And inside, right?
There it is.
Wait, am I building?
get this oh
yeah oh yeah
there's worth like not a lot though which kind of sucks but
we're we're making it work all right let's turn around again
let's turn around oh yeah you're you're you're you're you're
you every little bit counts Well, we do need the big bugs.
The container ship is a lot.
Wait,
no, no, that one, yeah.
doors they were right there what do you mean miss i shot
through the front doors
directly straight okay wait am i going nope just a little
more yeah i meant it okay oh shoot i'm not at the right
angle here either which sucks you know
Okay, we gotta like go in through here.
We gotta exit through here and then turn around.
I did get a sub.
Holy cow.
Okay, all right.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, okay.
Alright guys, let's get this.
Straight in, straight in, straight in.
Like that.
Yeah!
I might need to go restock though.
All right, now we turn around here and we do the other side.
Which is...
Right in front of us.
Alright,
let's go refuel.
Or, like, get more missiles.
It's kind of far, but...
We need to go do it.
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, good job, guys.
What do you mean to ski?
We'll grab some little things on the way.
Okay.
I just realized I didn't use my specials again.
Bye-bye.
Let's change my altitude just in case.
Or let's, like, get a little bit lower, you know.
Check behind you.
What's behind me?
Oh, they're, like, coming up on me?
Yeah.
I see him.
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
Okay.
We'll use it on the next thing, for sure.
The next area so that we can...
get our 500.
Dang, we're still pretty far.
I'm...
Oh, it might be really hard, actually.
No, please.
I don't want to do this all over again.
Oh, I don't want to do this again.
This mission is pain.
It takes...
It's such a long mission, and the map is huge, and
everything is...
Uh...
There's one close to the resupply line.
Yes, there is.
You're right.
Maintain courage and course to...
review.
Oh, okay.
I have to review.
I need more.
Okay.
Base.
Red vector 060, 12 miles.
I'm scared.
I'm not gonna lie.
I'm nervous.
Red vector 060, 8 miles.
Come on, can we get, like, better things than that?
Why isn't an ally blocking on with it?
Why am I not locked on with anything?
Like, legit question.
I'm, wait, I'm like, why is it?
Oh, it's long range.
Okay, okay.
Warning, incoming from Stonehenge.
Wait, hey, please!
Why is nothing...
You still dogged on?
Enemy facility destroyed.
Oh, a minute and a half.
10 seconds to impact.
Oh, shit.
8, 7, 6, 6, 6, 6, 5, 4, 8, 5, 4, 3, I might be dead.
I might be dead.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Wait,
I thought El Sam were to...
Um...
Were to ground, are they not?
Are they air?
Fox 2, Fox 2.
Enemy facility destroyed.
AA guns destroyed.
Come on, come on.
Surface target destroyed.
Destroyed.
Enemy facility destroyed.
Yeah!
Oh, it was so close!
All enemy facilities heavily damaged.
Our troops should face minimal resistance.
Mission complete.
All aircraft, RTB.
RTB, okay.
Oh my god!
So, to use the LCM, I should probably have been like more
higher up, is that, because Because I thought, like, long...
His displeasure was destroyed.
Oh, wow.
Next mission has one of the funniest dubs of a Japanese name
you'll hear, by the way.
Oh, I'm excited.
Holy cow.
Oh, my God.
Sun Tzu did a great job covering...
Covering Play-On!
Thank you!
Officer Mint, definitely best girl.
Higher up it...
I tried to get...
Maybe it's, like, really far.
Because I was, like...
I felt like I was pretty far, but it was just not...
It's fine, it's whatever.
I don't care, I did...
The mission's over.
We did it!
Oh!
That one was painful.
Escort.
Oh, I love escort missions.
Sign me up.
You did it in two tries.
That was great.
Two civilian aircraft flying through the hills region
northwest of Los Canas are under threat of attack by erosion
fighters.
On board are the engineers responsible for Stonehenge as
well as their families.
They are offering information in exchange for amnesty and
permission to defect to a high staff member state.
One of the aircraft is flying at an extremely low altitude
due to some unknown problem.
Your mission is to protect both aircraft from enemy
fighters.
Make sure they exit the combat area safely.
Oh it's actually an escort mission.
Have a nice flying mint.
See you later.
Thank you.
All right.
Oh, thank god.
No one in the... No one on the ground.
Wait, that means...
Oh, this guy is new.
EF 2000 fighter.
Delta wing air superiority fighter with high-tech Canards?
What does that mean?
Eurofighter.
The mobility is in the speed of crazy.
I want to try the Eurofighter.
There's a little mini-wing on those.
Oh, wait, I'll have to get a better look.
I'll have to get a better look.
Let me just sell everything.
I kind of like just buy what I need, you know what I mean?
When I need it.
Oh,
this guy's also new.
R.M.
Oh, what?
Delta Wing Carrier Base Fighter with a large payload.
Oh, wow, yeah.
How do you say that?
Rafale?
Zifrance.
I've never seen a plane with a selfie stick.
That's his little tiny arm and he's saluting.
What are you talking about?
He's like, yes, sir.
Yes, sir.
Rafaali.
Rafaio.
It's the Rafaali.
Let's try this one.
The Eurofighter.
isn't that a port for refueling yes yeah he's 07 07ing
everybody spread oh no oh well what does he come with oh
well i guess uh yeah we have There's no ground targets.
XLA-A's.
Baguette plane.
We're good then?
Okay.
I did save her.
I mean, I think I did.
We'll just do our... I like to have the second one just in
case the first one gets corrupted or something.
Alright.
We already have air-to-air...
I'll try it if I don't like it.
Oh yeah, here we go.
Whoa!
I tore my first pair of pants at dojo today.
Right down the middle.
That means good luck, right?
That means you got a fat ass!
Good job!
Escort the civilian aircraft.
Is it just me?
This is Sky Eye.
Please describe your situation.
I'm on my way!
This is First Officer Nagase.
What?
Nagase.
Oh, they're down here.
Hello, friends.
Where is my target?
Oh, we can.
Bandit at 2 o'clock.
Don't let the passengers see what's going on out there.
Are we almost there?
Uh, yeah.
Don't worry about it.
This is Flight 702.
The ISAF plane has the illusions tied up.
We just made it.
Oh, yeah.
Mobius 1, there's another bandit closing in on Flight 701 at
6,000 feet.
Okay, 6,000.
I'm at, like, 23,000 feet right now.
Let's go assist the ISAF escort.
cabin pressure could you please climb could you please climb
could you please climb oh shoot
ah hit missile hit Fox 2 Fox 2 Mobius 1 shot down a target
yes I did yes I did you guys are saying so many things and I
honestly I can't read the chat right now so you could be
yelling at me and you're literally yelling into the void
sorry so sorry for you nice this is flight 701 scramble to
fire engines and ambulance back at base nice this is flight
702 several the russian military aircraft are inbound and
closing rapidly obius one hostiles at 23 000 feet don't let
them get oh my god They're just making me go there.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Maintain altitude.
We're losing too much fuel.
I'm trying.
I think that might be okay.
Uh, where's the next guy?
Uzi?
Oh, I'm the big target.
What are you?
What are you saying about me, huh?
Oh, shoot.
Ah, don't get me hiding, I hesitated.
I don't like flying so close to the action, even if he is on
our side.
I'm trying to help you!
The bakery.
Come on, come on.
Come on.
Give me time, please!
Thank you!
Take it.
Missile shot, trashed.
I'm also in missile range.
I think we're fine.
Yes, okay.
Yes.
How many more do I have to go through?
Is it just until time is out?
I just have to...
Yeah, that's me.
Yeah.
Okay.
Holy cow!
There's so many of them!
This is Air Ixium Flight 701.
We're carrying civilians.
Don't shoot.
I don't think they care.
We have civilians on board.
Hold your- Wait, did I just shoot one?
Oh, shoot.
I can't see the sign is in my eyes.
We'll do our best.
You guys got them?
Okay.
Alright, where's the next guy?
Oh, there he is.
Oh,
that's my friend.
Oh my god, the sun is really in my eyes.
Where'd he go?
There he is.
Come on!
Yeah, baby.
Oh!
Mobius 1, Sky Eye here.
Both aircraft have exited the combat area safely.
There were no losses.
success.
Yippee!
All passengers and crew are safe.
Please thank the fighter.
What's up?
Where's Tri?
Let's go!
This is why I like dog fighting.
There's so much more but also they weren't even like
shooting at me or anything so it was like so they weren't
even were they fighting?
I couldn't tell honestly.
All passengers and crewed from both aircraft were examined
by an ISAF medical officer and are in good health.
Several states...
I know I wasn't their target, but like...
...the defectors and their families.
What an S!
Wow!
All right.
Woohoo!
Base combat four kind of easy.
Hey!
Maybe for you!
Maybe there were some people that play ace combat literally
every single day delivered to their base.
This meant that an enemy who had to be fought by those means
was close at hand.
The resistance blew up the squadron's runway.
Yellow four suffered light shrapnel wounds.
Though the runway could be fixed, the complete loss of
reserve supplies was a heavy blow.
Logistics support became infrequent following the Allied
operations.
I knew this because Yellow Squadron's The crew chief belly
ached about this all the time to me.
I won't complain if I buy the farm while I'm airborne, but I
can't stand being taken out while I'm grounded.
Now I understand 13's feelings.
The hog!
Reports of the Stonehenge air raid came in.
Yellow four on me with the others.
With no bombs.
But her plane was in bad shape.
It needed an engine replacement badly.
Wait, is that yellow four done for?
Stonehenge offensive?
Oh!
Done for...
We will attack Stonehenge.
The only weapon that has plagued ISAF for so long.
Since it was designed to shoot down asteroids, a few small
fighters flying unpredictable high-speed courses There's a
mission in 7 called Stonehenge Defensive.
According to the defectors, its central VCMG I didn't
remember what it was called, I just remember it being
Stonehenge.
Unless this system is destroyed, our mission will be very
difficult to execute.
HQ predicts a 40% casualty rate for all deployed aircraft.
It'll be a tough mission.
This is why it was in disrepair in seven.
Yeah!
I'm gonna destroy it!
Dismissed.
There's only seven targets on the ground.
of the cannons in this one okay get in there and let
stonehenge know how you feel all right 40 casualty rate is
insanely high for a mission it's literally a suicide mission
oh gosh yeah for anyone wondering i did play seven i have
played seven so Oh, whoops, I don't know, I'm gonna post
that.
Wait, the hell again while you're there.
Oh, detective.
Cell.
Okay, let's go.
It's a suicide.
I don't want YouTube getting mad at me.
Sewer surfing.
Slip and slide.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, I was like, dang.
What is that?
I was looking at just the stats, not the good.
Wait, what do we have?
Any new ones?
This one is not new.
Oh, wait.
Yes, it is.
Wait.
Oh, no, it's not.
Just kidding.
Yeah, of course.
How could I forget the selfie stick?
Oh, I see the...
Am I saying it right, canards?
Oh, my gosh.
It looks like a catfish.
It's so cute.
The part of town with turtles.
Yeah, it's like a goofy mustache.
It's so cute.
Oh my gosh.
This one looks really nice.
I'm not gonna lie.
The baguette.
Oh, weewee.
The Raphael.
Very fun.
Or is...
What the...
Oh my gosh, wait.
how artistic is it to have one mustache like this guy like
you know one half of your mustache
get these get the baguette plane very fast
canard means duck in french oh yes i felt like i knew it
before or like knew like heard that word before oh my gosh i
took french for like a really many number of years i learned
french in school many years i could never get i could never
the pronunciation was always so anard wing the muscle one i
remember
I remember...
I think I know how to count to four.
One, two, wait, one, two, three, four, seven, seven.
All I remember how to say is I speak French badly.
Do you speak English, please?
Okay, should I try it?
Let's try it.
Why not?
It's got good mobility, good defense, decent air to ground,
good speed.
Oh, whoops.
Let's try it.
She hates ground attack missions in this one.
Wait till she sees the ground attack missions in five, where
you have no return.
Oh, she oblique is coming.
Take a good time to practice, yo, Fawn, Fawn, Fawn, Joe, no!
Dick's new.
Yeah.
Just sweet.
Bananas.
You are bananas?
You are bananas.
B-A-N-A-N-A-S.
Oh, whoops.
I did not mean to press that.
Sorry, I keep meaning to go to buy.
Let's see what we got.
for you
I am nervous about using the lassoes again because I maybe
maybe maybe Stonehenge surely you for a super weapon you
would have well okay hold on I'm remembering I'm thinking
back to how Stonehenge was in ace combat okay there was
there were some hills but it was mostly desert flat was that
a lady gaga here you have more space here yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah these are air to air though we would want the air
to ground i believe it's the same here mint the taste what
does that you you hate me
because of the mission update trust me someone in chat is
not a holobank girl
yeah surely we don't need to worry about air to air okay I'm
gonna I'm gonna if I get one god wait i wish i could buy
both wait could i buy both
but then i have to choose one still i still have to choose
one if i get one god
yeah i can only equip one so it doesn't i mean i could buy
both but it doesn't really matter if i can only have one
oh wait anti-surface weapon which we're rains down multiple
bomblets.
Wait, didn't I try that one and I hated it?
Destroy all indicated targets.
Lock on from a very long range, okay.
Oh, VDSP.
Stonehenge is responsible for the loss of many aces.
me though.
Holy cow, I'm fast.
Oh,
that was close.
What is this?
Use your guns to destroy the jamming devices.
Jamming devices.
But this says it's just a guy.
Oh, whoops, I can't see them.
Oh, don't hurt me.
My bad.
I'm just going to ignore them.
Sam.
I can't believe we're here and it's working!
Oh, God!
Ouch, I ate that.
Oh my gosh, they don't stop.
They really don't stop.
Wait.
Oh my gosh.
Because I'm going slow.
Yeah, because I...
Well, I mean...
Do I need to go fast?
Ooh!
Target hit.
Okay.
Be easy to destroy.
Say your prayers.
Hit.
Target hit.
Where's my frangit?
I'm just, I'm just blindly.
Oh, shoot.
Dang it.
You can't lock on.
Okay.
Wait, go to the center.
Oh, is that the jamming thing?
Ah, I see, I see.
Obius 1, Fox 2.
Okay, wait, uh...
Wait, I'm messing...
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Wait, uh...
What's my altitude?
My altitude is kind of crazy.
Okay.
Wait.
Don't worry about me.
They say stay low altitude.
I stay the lowest.
Okay.
Yay!
Yeah!
Okay, I did it.
Missile head.
Oop!
Six targets remaining.
Bandit and Firefire.
Fox 2, Fox 2.
Fox 2.
Just don't end.
I'm hitting it.
Target hit.
I'm just going in a circle now.
Okay.
something that big can move AA guns destroyed AA good I'll
get more AA guns
I'm working on it I'm working on it
I'm just like going in circles the
other way no I'm not I'm flying in circles Destroyed?
Target destroyed.
What do you mean?
Where's the yellow squad?
We don't need to worry about them.
Don't go down.
Wait, no, please.
I'm trying.
I think I'm the only one attacking this thing.
Yeah, we're cutting it close.
Don't worry about it.
I'm an ace, you guys.
For real.
Miss!
It was right there.
Alright.
There we go.
What do you mean get out of there?
I'm destroying it!
Oh, isn't that what I'm supposed to do?
Destroy it!
This is the last one.
I just, I've got to destroy it.
Oh, I put it up.
Stonehenge with my own two hands.
Uh, dang it.
Wait, hold on.
I gotta, like, recircle.
Why is she turning close like this?
Because it's exciting, isn't it?
Aren't you excited?
You're in Stonehenge!
Yahoo!
Actually, I thought that I couldn't go above 2000.
I thought I couldn't go above the 2000 feet.
Uh-oh.
Is it the yellow spot?
Yeah?
We get it?
Oh gosh!
Are you sure about that?
Oh, they're behind me.
Oh, they're right behind me, aren't they?
Oh my god, look at that.
coming in they're so cool leave them to move what happened
that is awful oh I think he destroyed one wait oh wait what
yellow yellow anyone see four get out The other aircraft are
withdrawing.
That's a confirmed kill on a yellow.
It's a complete victory for the good guys.
Wait, did I kill her?
It's just me going around and around in circles.
I'm sorry, it's the most boring gameplay you've...
It's not his girlfriend.
He didn't care about her, I think.
Though he lost four.
13 never openly showed his sorrow.
Oh my god.
But I found out.
He was alone, quietly gazing at the handkerchief Yellow 4
left behind.
When he felt my eyes upon him, he said, No matter what, she
can't complain.
She went up with her plane in disrepair.
Oh, my God.
Pilots are responsible for their planes.
It took one missile.
I didn't...
He then went on and spoke of the time when they first met.
I just shot once.
He spoke of when she was just a girl.
Oh.
before he trained her, before she became a fighter pilot.
His words weren't directed at me in particular.
He was keeping a precious memory alive by speaking those
words, the hint of perfume on her keepsake handkerchief.
Yellow Squadron's pilot turnover ran high.
The skilled ones went in to shore up other units while
rookies with little airtime transferred in.
Oof.
Yellow Thirteen posted an allied paper faxed over by
headquarters.
It praised the pilot who destroyed Stonehenge.
Me.
Thirteen said to everyone, Me.
Look.
Here's something worthy of praise.
Oh my god, he's obsessed with me.
Even among the enemy there are men like this.
Not all of them are despicable bastards who rob our wings
through cowardly sabotage.
I stared at the barkeep's daughter as she winced at those
words.
Yes.
Jeez, this game's awesome lot.
I could tell.
Told you to put on the Yowie hat.
Ooh, safe return.
Well, dang.
I...
Do you guys think we could do one more?
Or do we want to save the last six for Sunday if you think
Sunday will probably take me a long long time I mean there
was that one mission that took me like 30 minutes so the
missions tend to vary based on me this one is kind of short
up to you one more this is a filler mission so clear it oh I
mean that works too mission 13
One more!
What if we did one more?
I return you to recon plane with engine trouble.
Yippee!
Wait, I get to use the gun!
Let's do the case later.
Oh!
Whoa.
Destroy as many jammers in the valley as possible and get
that recon plane safely home.
Oh, okay.
So you'll need to find the airships visually and destroy
them with your machine guns.
Gun, gun, gun.
You cannot use missiles here in the mission gun.
An only mission gun and it takes the entire mission time to
come.
But look at how many there are.
Wait, so I can shoot as many or as little as I want?
Or...
Is there like, is it like, uh, you must get this many points
again?
Sounds like me when I open a pack of biscuits.
Just one more.
Only 13.
Gotta hit a minimum of...
Let's try it.
We can just try it.
A10, I think it is your time.
But does it even matter, though?
Maybe for, like, the speed.
So I could just be like a slow burner.
You know?
Is it time for the A10 war tag?
Yeah, it really doesn't matter, right?
You may want to take it slow.
I got the strike eagle.
Oh.
Is this it?
So cute!
Listen to select me.
music is what I was talking about yay look at his face he's
like hey boss put me in put me in the sky put me in the sky
boss good job so five minute time to get good with guns
you'll need to train for ace combat five anyway yeah oh my
gosh Jehuty that's a series I need to play too Wow, this
one's really well-rounded.
Hold on, let me...
Amazing work on Stonehenge and Yellow Forming, and the coast
of Akiva.
That was impressive.
I don't think it was impressive.
I flew in circles, and then I...
I flew in circles in the night.
I shot once, and I killed it.
It was so stupid.
I was so worried about What the hell?
Ace Combat 7 makes you so...
I don't know.
I'm curious if I played it again now.
It's so funny.
Let's try it.
This guy is happy to be here.
You want to take the W.
So funny.
Peak dog foot.
Because in 7 you are defending it.
That's true.
Ugh, that's true.
And it's like non-stop.
That's crazy.
It's a really long mission, I remember.
Or maybe it just feels long in my brain.
Yeah!
But we can't really...
Rock it!
Oh, maybe this would be good though.
We don't need homing, obviously.
We just need the... we just need a pew pew.
the rocket's not good here it's not oh oh never mind sorry i
didn't even realize we had this okay we'll go with that one
if the rocket's not good the rocket launcher is not good
score at least 1300 points within the time limit and
continue to destroy enemy forces all right time to try uh
holy oh uh what do they look like here's an airship jamming
device there are others as well destroy them all
uh i it's like this is leopard flying north of loam ravine
oh the jam is disabled yet sky eye the blips are them but i
don't see them on here oh wait are they in the sky
oh oh
wait this is kind of fun
oh shoot Oh, I'm shooting?
What I'm missing?
Fastest... I'm fastest freak!
I'm fastest freak!
Wait, we could go back and get that guy.
Within six minutes.
The music is so chill.
blimps!
Blimps!
I need blimps around.
Wait, oh, I'm too high up.
Oh.
I need to learn how to...
This
is so chill.
Got him.
More.
Moab, handle it.
Stop making me want to play bloons.
Got him.
Did
I see any more?
Maybe like this would be better.
For like more visibility.
Okay.
Before the U2 arrives.
Far do my bullets travel to.
Can't tell if...
There we go.
Alright.
Uh, any more?
I see you on the radar.
Gotta
afford to go faster.
Where are you guys?
Nice shot.
Here's your...
So true.
okay I'm searching for real like they're just they're just
escaping me I'm the top crews of youtubers I don't is that
is that a good thing they seem higher up than not
oops oops oops my bad that was silly I mean I'm I'm like
nervous about making it because I can't find them.
I'm just gonna go really fast until I see one in my...
Go low?
You think they're lower?
I don't see any so low.
Oh, there's one.
Oh, there's two!
Thank you.
Whoever said go low?
You're awesome.
Oh my gosh, you're awesome.
There's three of them.
I can't.
Break.
I don't know how to use my break, sorry.
Mobius one, recon aircraft will transit soon.
Radar is still blacked out.
I'm trying, I'm trying.
I'm
gonna stall.
Mobius one is unsure if Mobius one will complete this
mission.
Mobius one is also scared.
Mobius one is scared.
Three miles were almost there.
Okay, please.
Stop scaring me.
Stop pressuring me.
If you wanted this done quickly, you should have sent more
people!
Radar noise interference is leveling off.
The reconnaissance aircraft should be able to get through
soon.
This would have been a great, like...
Oh, I haven't played in a couple days.
I need to remember how to play the game type of mission.
You know?
This is Leperdon.
Shit, shit, shit.
Yes!
I'm giving you radar.
What do you want from me?
Oops, wrong way.
Oh, got him anyway.
Nice job.
Thank you.
Could always redo it.
So true, actually.
Oh, there's my friend.
Wait, I want to see him.
where's my friend there's my friend what shoot down all
bandits and protect the reconnaissance aircraft oh oh okay
oh they know me come
at me I dare you
you right
Oh shoot.
Where are you?
Radar lock.
Fox 2.
Dang.
I thought I had him.
Maybe?
Destroyed.
Yeah I did.
Oh shoot, dang it.
I think I missed again.
Dang it.
Whoa.
What is that?
Oh.
Almost hit you.
I know.
That was crazy.
I think I got him.
Oh.
Obious one destroyed the target.
Bandits confirmed shot down.
Ah!
Where's my friend at?
Recon aircraft is secure.
Mission is complete.
Oh, oh, what if I just, what if I just die?
What if I just, phew?
Wee, look at that.
I'd be spitting.
Watch, watch, watch.
Watch me spit.
So good.
I'd be spitting.
The recon flame brought back data on Megalith.
This is the superweapon designed by the Erusions to replace
Stonehenge.
Analysis by the intelligent unit leads to the conclusion
that victory hinges on ending this war before Megalith is
deployed.
Megalith?
Me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me-me.
You can lose a mission if you die in the last moment.
even when you finish six I do know that I do actually know
that yeah all right well then we will have five missions to
complete next time a weapon to defeat megalith megalith with
Stonehenge out of condition the landing operations are
underway in the northern part of the mainland In response,
the Erujans have launched large numbers of cruise missiles
against the ice after heavy forces.
Our radar is unable to pick up these missiles that lie at
ultra-low altitude.
Failure to destroy these missiles will put our troops in
danger.
Your mission is to shoot and destroy each and every cruise
missile.
Missile!
Well, that's for Sunday Minto to worry about.
That's kind of... that sounds...
this mission is it gonna be bad don't forget listening to
the menu music we'll listen to the menu music we'll do it
it's annoying I see one more no no no we'll do it next time
we'll do it next time maybe It might... I don't... We won't
worry about it today.
We won't worry about it today.
It's fully air to air at least.
Okay.
Thank you!
Thank you so much, Amidori!
You really breezed through these missions.
That was so fun!
That was so so fun!
Next time we will do the last five missions.
We'll beat the game and become the Ace Combat.
Thanks for the streaming, so nice spitting.
Routine is so sus.
Next they're going to use some kind of megalith.
Well anywho, we'll see what that's all about on Sunday.
Have a great night.
You too, Dorgo.
Thank you so much for the ping.
Thank you.
You're on the offensive after Stonehenge got taken down.
And I will fight.
Not so tempo, thank you so much for the tag, good day, thank
you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Metal kiss?
What is a megalith, if not a mega kiss?
Thank you for streaming today, thank you for watching today!
I'm enjoying Ace Combat 4 so much.
Sad that we will only have a few missions left but
unfortunately that's how games go and if you enjoy them you
can always play them again but thank you guys so so much we
will beat the game on Sunday mega gear yeah exactly make me
thank you thank you thank you nah well thank you so much for
the tech gift thank you yeah we still have the other games
as well so it's whatever I told you that you're doing great
Capito, comparing, you've made great progress!
You're awesome, you can make it to the end.
Thank you, Papias!
I suppose I best go back and work then.
Phil, thank you!
Good luck with work.
Hi, man, I'm going to MRC tomorrow.
Any MGS?
Oh, she cuts ideas.
Oh, yes.
Um, yes.
You can go to anywhere, the streets, because it's New York.
And also, uh, Federal Hall!
Federal Hall you must go to.
Hopefully it's not under construction anymore.
But you must go to Federal Hall for Oshikaz Metal Gear.
Yeah.
Thank you, Mint Aishto.
Thank you!
Good dream boss, y'all.
We're working hard and it shows.
Thank you!
My skills have improved a lot.
No crashes at all.
I can't...
I don't...
Honestly, especially since I haven't played...
haven't played this game or rather like ace combat in
general in years it's kind of insane i don't know if it's me
having gotten better or just that this game is easier maybe
bit both but so many close calls today another incredible
stream not that i care oh it's here reminds me of top gun
music yeah it's got that like 80s sound.
Assault has made some short videos that recreate the events
of several Ace Combat missions.
I highly recommend his Invisible Fleet.
Shattered skies and blockade ones.
They're absolute cinema.
Oh, I'll check them out.
Thank you, Marflazer.
You were in Ace today.
Yeah.
What can I say?
You're a gamer.
It's just that I haven't been playing this type of game, so
it's like...
Like...
It's not that I feel like my skills as a gamer got better...
For me to be better.
Minto has improved a lot as a soldier.
As a gamer!
Thank you, Liquid.
Maybe I've just watched Top Gun enough times, maybe.
If I watched Top Gun so many times...
There was one time I was watching it...
I was on a plane and I was flying with my friend.
And I was like, I'm going to go to...
Oh, turbulence is happening.
I'm going to watch Top Gun.
So I like to watch certain parts of Top Gun.
Like, because I like to feel immersed.
And I, like, went immediately to the part that I wanted to
watch.
And she was like, what is wrong with you?
She was like, how do you know exactly where to go in the
movie?
I don't know.
I've just watched it enough times.
This game was developed during the 90s for a release around
2003, so it makes sense.
Yeah, yeah.
And then I also know I don't like any of the romance parts
in Top Gun 2.
In Top Gun Maverick.
So I just skip those as well.
And I know exactly where to go to skip the scene.
Sometimes coming back with fresh eyes This is what you need
to improve.
It's your old practice becoming more instinctive.
I forgot about the romance.
I don't care about it at all.
Like, the relationship makes...
Actually, I prefer the romance in one than I prefer in two.
The one in two is really, like, just shoved in there.
But the romance in one is, like, kind of okay.
We don't need the corny love stuff in our fighter jet movie.
Exactly.
I forgot what had robert.
It's what?
It's me?
Good.
Oh, Nagoshi!
Oh, the Japanese name!
It's me!
Nagoshi!
Me.
Nagoshi.
Iceman and Maverick were meant to be.
It's true!
I'll say it with my whole soul!
Nagoshi?
Anyways, thank you guys so much!
I finished a little bit earlier than my usual stream, so
have a good day, have a good night, and I will see you when
I see you next!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank
you, thank you, thank you, thank you, bye, bye, bye, bye,
bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye,